was it was emotional like I I know I've
said to all of you before I have no
doubt uh this is the right time for me
for my party government country but of
course it's emotional the last eight
years have been the best in my life I as
I've just said in there I'll never do it
and it's important or as special as this
again and I'm so grateful for the
opportunity I'm proud of my record I of
course have made mistakes there are
things I wish I'd done differently or
better but I'm proud of the record and I
look forward to seeing my successor
build upon it as I take my place
um
pretty emotional I
you
've possibly struggled a bit more than I
hoped I would to to not shed a few tears
in there
I think particularly what I'm feeling
right now and I felt this when I was
thanking people who without whom I would
not have lasted any time as as first
Minister you know ultimately the job
that I do is the highest office in the
land but it's still fundamentally about
people and the hardest part of this
decision is the people I'm going to miss
nor seeing every single day sorry
you know show me a human being or a
politician or a government Minister that
doesn't have regrets and I showed you
somebody that's not properly human and
I'm not going to do that today no
Independence I would love to have been
the leader who took Scotland's
Independence but I think I've said this
to many of you as well for me I've
campaigned for Independence literally
since I was 16 years old for me
attaining Independence is much much much
much more important than the person who
leads us there and I have no doubt
Scotland will become independent so you
know I'll have time to reflect later on
my time in office I'm sure many of you
will continue to reflect on that time
and proud I won't go through them I've
said in there some of the things I'm
proudest of this has been a privilege
it's been a privilege every single day
you know I have led Scotland through a
period in our history that nobody would
have chosen covered
shape the country I I think in ways that
we probably don't yet fully understand
it shaped me it has undoubtedly changed
me as a person and I think when we look
back it will
be seen to have defined my my time as
first minister so you know and that
created that really difficult time
for everybody and I've said before my
job was not the toughest in the country
by any stretch of the imagination but I
felt during that period the bond with
the Scottish people that sustained me
and I hope it helped the country through
do you have regrets about how the
party's uh no I have great confidence in
the future of my party and I think I
alluded to this in there but I didn't
tell the full stories forgive me if some
of you have heard this story before I
went to my first ever SNP meeting in the
volunteer rooms in Irvine and the
Cunningham South constituency in 1986.
and I always remember that meeting
because it was my first but there was
everybody there was on a high because
the zone to hear from the herald the
system three opinion poll had come out
that day and we were at 12 and the
reason everybody was on a high it was
the first time anyegis we'd been in
double figures
my party has come such a long way and
it's come such a long way through hard
work
serving Scotland and being a team
solidarity and unity and you know even
in the last few days when there's been
hyperbolic phrases used about collapse
and all sorts of things you know you
look at most opinion polls and they
still show the SNP way ahead of anyone
else now my successor should not take
that for granted I have never taken that
for granted but I have real confidence
in whoever my successor is to continue
to build on the success of the party and
the government but to do that they must
remain focused on the interests and the
priorities of people across the country